okay
well i did not get the job in new york
but i got the real prize domestic bliss
jan made me breakfast this morning
well she bought the milk
it's soy this
is why i do it that's what i have to
come home to
she probably won't be up for a few hours
this is going to be a very good year
very good jan is at home
jim is back my protege ryan is a
corporate
good stuff um andy and dwight
are rocking the sales team i feel very
[Music]
blessed
after a clean strike to the chest
stomach or kidneys
i will separate you and award a point
first person of three wins all right
yes sensei a lot of rules a lot of rules
on the street we didn't have any rules
maybe one
no kicks to the groin home for dinner
schmidt
what the hell was that it's white yes no
okay eat it all right that's the way no
more play dirty huh
okay game on man sweep the leg yeah i'm
coming at you man
okay purple belt okay i got it
no i got a pant that was my pants no
points for pants
wait you have no look no you're
something you're something
god you look like an idiot
come on do that again do that again i'll
tear you off
okay oh you can't see
9.
[Music]
do you want me to stop dating your mom
is that how we're gonna get past this
cause i will
yes well that is not gonna happen then
why'd you even offer
because i assumed that you want me to be
happy because i
want you to be happy michael let me make
this very easy for you
i could give it about your happiness
stop dating
my mother you know what i'm gonna start
dating her even harder
what's that supposed to mean you know
what it means
hey shut it yep
proceed straight well we're all for six
last chance is the elmhurst country club
other side of the lake on the southeast
side
i don't get it i really don't get it i
thought this would work
do everything i had at that guy nothing
that's how it goes sometimes you know
you lose everything and everything falls
apart
and eventually you die and no one
remembers you
that is a very good point dwight make a
right turn
wait wait wait wait no no no it means
bear right
not there it said right it said take a
right no no no no no look
it it means go up to the right bare
right over the bridge and hook up with
307. make a right maybe it's a shortcut
dwight it said go to the right
it can't mean that there's a leg there
it knows where it is
the machine stop yelling at me
remain calm i have trained for this okay
exit the window here we go make a u-turn
if possible
ah
come on come on
ladies and gentlemen
i have some bad news meredith was hit by
a car
what what oh where it happened this
morning in the parking lot
i took her to the hospital and the
doctors tried to save her
life they did the best that they could
and she is going to be okay what is
wrong with
you now this
is the forklift you need you need a
license to operate
this machine that means the upstairs
office workers can't
drive it quiz mike should you drive the
forklift
no hey you're gonna you're gonna hurt
yourself mike
stand clear mike get off of the lift
please come on now fine i'm fine
come on look
we'll get somebody to clean that up
we're the ones that got to clean that up
damn it michael we have to have this
thing serviced
i can and i have no no no no no i said
should you
you should not drive it you should not
drive the forklift
you're not allowed to drive the forklift
it's not safe you don't have a license
hey hey
this is ridiculous you think they'd
discourage people from bringing in
balloons
[Music]
as good as rescued where do you suppose
all the wig makers of london go to
obtain
their human hair do you think
so you think
so you think he's asylum why not
[Music]
oh my god okay it's happening everybody
stay calm what's the procedure
everyone what's the procedure go no no
no no you will not die
staley stanley you will not die stanley
stanley barack is president you are
black
sadly i'm gonna give him a mouth about
no no no no no don't give him out the
mouth for this
you're gonna swallow his tongue open
your mouth michael swan don't follow him
i'm fine leave me alone
excuse me for a second
so how do you guys know each other
i was just babysitter and now you guys
are dating
it's purely carnal that's all you need
to know
would you write down your email because
i have just
so many questions email
nevermind okay
all right there we go
oh okay that's nice
everybody enjoying their meal
come on michael you're you're
interrupting you're kidding me god
you say rayon is silent but deadly and
then you expect me not to make farting
noises with my mouth
what is this please sit down you know
what we're not gonna die of radon we're
gonna die of boredom
yeah right and if i had a gun
with two bullets and i was in a room
with hitler bin laden
and toby i would shoot toby twice no
that's not okay you're all right really
funny and then you went too far
all right since i am the boss i will
drive as well who wants shotgun
you can't be serious you ran a woman
over this morning everyone inside the
car was fine
stanley
you